what's happening reject nation so today
we're gonna do another try not to laugh
wanted to mix it up this time
with an offensive compilation from a
little show
called south park now i gotta tell you
guys
i haven't seen much of south park i saw
the movie ages ago
i've seen a few episodes when i was a
little kid so odds are
99.9 of whatever's in this compilation
i've never seen
and i know south park though doesn't
really hold back
so should be my kind of comedy try not
to laugh
let's get this show on the road
okay well maybe a new kid maybe you
should share some of your thoughts
okay well this isn't really going that
well um
okay boys i want to do an exercise with
you um i have some kids here to help us
out
when we're trying to have some therapy
the first thing we need to do is
is take out our resentments okay so
let's have our resentments come out come
on out over come over resentment
okay and then in a relationship we also
have expectations okay
because expectations lead to resentment
which of course brings about accusations
come on out accusations
okay and then that of course leads to
victimization
and withdrawal now you've got to learn
to overcome
all of these things this is good are you
ready are you ready
go [ __ ] them up there they are right
there tweet greg oh go beat the [ __ ] out
of them
[Music]
internet we have to get there before
they do the police station i can't take
down the police are you crazy
yeah just let the freedom pals go do it
we can't do that guys
why not because at approximately 10 30
a.m this morning
classy was arrested by the police
[Music]
[Music]
that's enough just stand down kid
darn look i know why you're here you're
fed up
because you think all cops do is harass
black people
i know that to a young kid it can seem
like cops are racist and bigoted
but you can't believe what the media
tells you
cops are just people like you your
friends
your family people who work hard
get your ass upstairs sir and turn on
the alarm
again don't you see this is better for
everyone
phil
[Music]
what can i say you kids have me by the
balls the avengers music
almost not every prisoner we have here
is black
we actually do have one white guy
[Music]
this is a trap i'm sorry kids but you
left me no choice
are you still looking good no
those lips
hey kids you want some candy oh [ __ ]
it's jared you'll excuse me if i don't
want to watch this
and i believe we can help each other
have you heard of the super best friends
well it is i see man
a powerful superhero with the amazing
ability to talk to
fish and swim it's semen
that sea man it is my job to help all
creatures of the sea
and right now there is a gay fish who
wants help getting his mother into
heaven
i want to help the little gay fish but
all the other super best friends
keep saying they're too busy will you
help
then swim down to the water steps with
me don't worry my water defenses shall
protect you
and so the new kid dives down through
the water protected by semen
see man down to where the little gay
fish makes his home
[Music]
do not cry little fish i have returned
and with help
oh thank you steven you really think you
can help my mom get to heaven
it's sea man and yes i do this child has
incredible powers
all right if you get my mom into heaven
i will give you three million dollars
and some jewelry
just touch my little gay flipper and we
shall be magically transported to help
her
touching the gay fish's flipper semen
and his sidekick are transported to
valhalla
where another fish rides a unicorn i'm
here mama
is that you baby it's me we're gonna get
you to heaven mother just hold on this
kid's gonna help us
okay baby whatever you're saying
and so semen sidekick had to help the
gay fisher's mom fly to heaven on a
stream of rainbow unicorn farms
that's steve nice yes
that turns while we can all right one
two
[Music]
if it isn't the freedom pals and their
newest recruit
what have you done with the new kids
parents bad ass nothing yet
but when i'm finished with you i can't
say they'll be exactly safe
this has gone far enough we end it now
the only thing about the end is you
mysterio
we aren't gonna fight you coming now put
your stupid hand down and stop playing
games
we have to stop him you guys he's got
all the new kids followers now
even with their help you can't stab me
king we'll see about that [ __ ]
all right cartman you want us to kill
mitch connor
we'll [ __ ] kill him
[Music]
you see super craig once we know how to
do things to animals we can hopefully
apply them to mankind
you think having more asses is
impossible i tell you it's not
you see genetic engineering is not just
for animals and veggies
we are working towards helping people as
well here you can see genetic mutations
of my dead sun
most people don't remember that i once
had a young child named terence
well yeah i remember that kid i was
wondering whatever happened to him
terence was killed tragically
when some kids were playing barbra
streisand
oh jesus so you're doing this
all as a way to bring back your dead son
bring him back well of course not
i'm trying to give his dead body more
asses so he can finally rest in peace
now let's continue on to the fourth
floor now
but well here we are
the top floor of the building and the
end of our tour what are these
these horrible monstrous mistakes of
science
our new benefactor has asked that we
genetically alter some of the local six
years
and make them okay okay
why the [ __ ] would you do that what do
you mean why the [ __ ]
would you make genetically enhanced
sixth graders calm down super crazy
how do you think we paid for them right
our latest benefactor has asked for this
army of mutated sixth graders
to protect his altered cats what altered
cats
oh right over this way a view of his
cane healthy benefactor named
mr connor has donated money to have
stray cats enhanced
with more asses our company can add
asses to things at very competitive
rates
the problem is that cats seem to become
really aggressive when given more assets
they've proven to be quite deadly then
why would you bring a bunch of kids up
here
look there's nothing to worry about this
entire facility has a very complex
security grid
[Music]
huh that's never happened before oh [ __ ]
someone shut down the security grid
what do you mean
[Music]
hello
[Music]
where the [ __ ] are you mr connor if you
shut down the security grid then
everyone in this building is going to
die
what sometimes
[Music]
many acid cats
no dna that's like every douchebag
superhero movie ever yeah because it's
key
it's not cute no no it's cool because
it's like the ultimate enemy oh give me
a break
well anyways i wasn't able to finish
getting the new kids dna
so i had to resort to cloning a
different superhero
which superhero
merry christmas happy holidays y'all
yeah let's get [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] we're too late the new kid sets
us forward in time
to when carmen is already mayor you have
to take us back new kid
that's it before this all happened
it isn't working i think maybe the new
kid has a fractured butthole
fractured bubble that's ridiculous right
we have to get the kid to a doctor trash
be careful new kid south park is a
really scary place on
oh christmas boys merry christmas
i'm so [ __ ] up i feel like it's been
christmas for a year
[Music]
now oh be scared y'all we're simply here
to celebrate the coming of our lord
[Music]
pentagram
[Music]
it's over man wait a minute it's
christmas
i know who can help new kid you have to
pray to christ
[Music]
timmy
[Music]
keep pressing y just like we did in
church
[Music]
[Music]
stupid
[Music]
[Music]
well now maybe we can eat his flesh hail
satan oh
you little [ __ ] critters again huh
santa's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you
is
all the benefits of playing this game
ah south park man it's just as strange
and
weird as i remember them being no holds
borrowed these guys
they're so so whacked out there i love
them
i've never had comedy central um but i
have hbo max now and i saw that they did
like a pandemic special
so i wanted to watch that because like
when i was younger didn't have cable
growing up
so all i had were like two dvds of south
park that my brother once bought
and it was like eight episodes in total
with those two dvds so
i just rewatched those all the time and
then uh
eventually watch the movie whenever it
came out but that was it
so getting back in here like man i
really gotta start up south park from
the beginning
they are so funny to me
because they're so bizarre and then so
mean at the same time
that i'm like i don't wonder these guys
get away with it it's just
no way you can take it that serious it's
hilarious
they they wear that equal opportunity
offender banner with glee
and i feel like they really have a niche
where they've
perfectly harnessed the crude visual
value of the show
for the tone i love watching this video
game unfold
weirdly this happened to take place
during the christmas time too
so good timing on our end i felt an
endorphin boost
doing this like trying not to laugh all
the joy was just going to my brain i
felt
all the laughter were just like just
fermented in my air yeah
it was like festering joy in my brain
like this is so enjoyable i keep
watching this is so enjoyable
absolutely someone recommended this in
one of our family guys this uh i was
like recommend some other ones someone's
in south park so then uh we got this one
sent to us to recommend some other ones
you'd like us to experiment with because
uh i came pretty close to breaking on
this one i had to really contain my
laughter
especially the c-man part and swallows
and
swallowed that about broke me when i
actually took the time to read it
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that notification
bell
catch you guys soon hit that like button
[Music]
too